uh guess what my patience is run
out pansexuality is not inherently
biphobic and while yes i have seen
pansexual people use that label for
questionable reasons they pretty quickly
get it once you explain things to them
if you took all that energy you spend
calling people biphobic and saying
they're performing by erasure and just
educated them there would be less
biphobia i have had it with you
guys
what was that
i don't was that i was that in in human
english i don't know what any of that
means you know why this person's yelling
at me i don't know why you guys are
putting me through this i don't know why
i employ you i'm surrounded by
i think the only thing that we can take
away from this particular video is that
no one should ever use tiktok for any
reason
thank you